imagínense que nací en el año 1973
el año en que atlético nacional después
de 19 años gana su segundo título en el
fútbol colombiano
no siquiera mire que yo nací en 1970
donde fue la peor crisis institucional
que tuvo el independiente medellín tanto
fue la crisis que el equipo debe la
ciudad se fue a jugar a barrancabermeja
perdió la ficha pero ve tan casual y tan
bacano que hay mayor y quien es la época
los hinchas del medellín los hinchas del
nacional los jugadores los directivos
hicieron lo que conocemos nosotros como
la martillera para recoger plata para
volver a traer medellín a la ciudad
porque no pueden venir nosotros
np
así es
pero un tema importante y es que las
crisis no sólo generan en todos los
equipos para nosotros los los que somos
directivos de clubes no hemos sido
directivos de clubes todos los clubes
han tenido crisis en algún momento y así
es como nos pasó a nosotros en el año
2010 cuando llegue a ser el presidente
de atlético nacional ya tenía 36 años
ser el presidente más joven de llegar a
atlético nacional y después de nacional
tener tantas tantos logros
internacionales pues haber ganado la
copa libertadores en el 89 esta es la
época de kinder de zubeldía la época de
maturana con los puros criollos en el
2010 imagínense que teníamos crisis ya
que había había que solucionarlo no
hacemos de todo como verdad no ajeno
noveno a lo que me tocó a mí imaginé que
llegue en el 2013 o el 2014 a medida
medellín tenía de tener la fortuna de
haber sido presidente millonarios en el
y llegó también me encuentra una
compañía donde han pasado en los últimos
cuatro años cinco presidentes donde hay
una crisis económica donde no ganamos el
último diez torneos habíamos calificado
una o dos veces al octogonal crisis
total a mí también me tocó
y que hicimos de verdad nos propusimos
algo que fue muy importante y es volver
en el club atlético nacional hacer un
club grande hacer un club internacional
volvería a la hinchada ese
reconocimiento y esa pasión de nuevo por
ese equipo
darle satisfacciones de alegría
y en la junta directiva miren lo que me
ponen hacer fútbol equipo ganador fútbol
atractivo sostenible económicamente y
estable en el tiempo ustedes saben cómo
se logra eso
en ese momento yo tampoco pero empezamos
a trabajar con la junta directiva y
empezamos a meterle sistema empresarial
a al club volverla una empresa deportiva
y de ahí desmarcamos un direccionamiento
estratégico y ese direccionamiento
estratégico eduardo lo orientamos en un
corto mediano y largo plazo con unos
objetivos claros será el equipo como lo
ven ustedes ganador atractivo que le
gustará la hinchada fuera económicamente
rentable y que ganará títulos que será
lo que queríamos
pero no solo se queda en la teoría
teníamos que hacer la práctica ya
teníamos al menos el direccionamiento
hacia donde queríamos ir y ahora que
necesitamos contratar buenos técnicos
contratar buenos jugadores general de
las mejores condiciones de entrenamiento
entonces una instalación física y de ahí
empezar a desarrollar ese proyecto
así a hablarlo era muy bonito pero
después
de pasar y lo digo con orgullo tanto a
la chica ni a
pero la verdad no a hinchas de nacional
acá
bueno después de trasegar y de ir
pasando año a año fuimos creciendo
fuimos organizando nos fuimos ganando la
liga colombiana y empezamos a ponernos
unos horizontes entonces ya en un
mediano plazo en la liga en el corto
plazo era ganar los títulos colombianos
y volvernos contenedores locales y a su
vez cuando ganamos esos títulos locales
teníamos participación internacional
cuando teníamos participaciones
internacionales te tocó vivir alguna
entonces cuando es por molestar de
verdad con los hinchas de medellín
tratamos de además aquí se pone muy
nervioso
entonces tratamos de trabajar en ese
sentido y cada vez más ir consolidando
nos internacionalmente como para resumir
logramos estar sostenidos económicamente
generar en satisfacción esa alegría
nuestra hinchada lograr títulos
internacionales para nosotros el año
2016 que es una demostración o digamos
un caso de éxito demostrable que cuando
trabajamos con una planeación con una
organización y con unos objetivos claros
dándole a nuestros jugadores también
cuál eran las posibilidades y qué era lo
que queríamos de ser un club grande y
que el fútbol colombiano estaba a la par
del fútbol internacional ustedes pueden
ver de que logramos muchos títulos pero
no solo fue de cabeza mía sino haciendo
equipo entre junta directiva hinchada
jugadores y así es como uno trabaja
siempre en la planeación estratégica y
en la vida haciendo equipo
el logro de la copa libertadores fue el
máximo galardón que pudimos tener aguja
la alguna vez medellín pueda tener esa
posibilidad también y luego de verdad
con el respeto y con la humildad del
caso
después hablamos
jugar un torneo internacional como la
copa suramericana que estuvimos dos
veces con esa posibilidad la primera
vela perdido con corriere play en el
2014 que creíamos que iba a ser el
objetivo claro y que iba a ser el
lograble el 2016 que ustedes saben con
el tema de chapecó en sé que fue también
una tragedia muy grande que nos partió
el corazón a todos y que fue muy duro y
también hoy digamos un momento de
orgullo y de satisfacción que pocos
clubes han podido estar
en el mundial de clubes que bien es una
satisfacción muy grande en japón
perdieron con el caché pero bueno
estuvimos estuvimos en japón lo
disfrutamos y creo que nuestra hinchada
fue feliz con eso
otro tema importante producto de ese
premio que logramos de fair play de la
fifa por por el tema lost the best el
premio the best de fairfield fair play
de la fifa por haber seguido el título a
chapelco en sí yo creo que eso fue un
rubro también muy importante porque no
sólo marcó la tendencia deportiva del
club sino también una tendencia social
así como somos los medellinenses y somos
los colombianos somos solidarios somos
alegres y también pues digamos nos
unimos a las causas tristes para poder
digamos darle un momento de alegría a
alguien que sufrió pues digamos ese
momento así es que esa es mi historia en
el club y bueno te dejo eduardo para que
cuente la tuya y felicitaban
grandes grandes logros muchos títulos
pero yo les quería contar una historia
la que me tocó a mí juan imagínese en
que cuando llegó a medellín en esta
ciudad como todos conocen hay dos
equipos uno que acaba con taiwán que
gana todo
y hay uno que en ese momento no no está
en su mejor nivel deportivo uno que es
demostrar pues que tiene su accionista
de prestigio gran empresario y otro que
en ese momento nadie sabe quién era el
accionista de medellín
nos sentamos con los nuevos dueños del
medellín que son los que me invitan a
venir a la compañía y me siento con
ellos y me dicen eduardo nosotros
queremos una compañía que ni nos quite
ni que nos dé nosotros queremos una
compañía estable que la gente la quiera
que vuelvan a salir a la calle que
disfruten de ir al estadio que nos
sentemos en el palco y los veamos a
todos abrazarse queremos la compañía
cuando ellos me dicen esa esa historia
hoy saben lo que quieren muy facilísimo
imagínense que dijimos y hay que pensar
diferente porque no podemos salir a
hacer lo mismo que eso nacional 25 años
de una planeación a largo plazo pero lo
apuntamos a una planeación algo de
impacto que había que hacer ya y nos
dimos cuenta que en colombia nadie tenía
los estadios nacional si en la final a
manera el clásico
y muchas finales antes
vivimos los los equipos no llenan los
estadios porque no hacemos algo de
impacto y que se tiene el estadio en
nosotros que nos divirtamos que paremos
bueno pues que hicimos
hicimos un estudio oigan pero esta
historia va a tomar aquí el valor de las
matemáticas
medellín se administraba en el semestre
con siete pesos
dos pesos de esos gastos se cubrían con
la televisión otros dos pesos se cubrían
con el mercadeo que se hacía en el
momento que teníamos dos patrocinadores
faltaban tres pesos esos tres pesos nos
dimos cuenta que llenando al estadio en
una final con 45.000 personas se
recogían los tres pesos que le dimos a
la junta
oiga porque no nos permiten hacer lo
siguiente con el apoyo de ellos pues y
en el entusiasmo lo que queríamos lograr
le dimos tenemos que por el precio de
una boleta la gente poder a todos los
partidos pero con una condición que la
tiene que comprar los 45.000 si no
devolvemos la plata
para el del invitamos a los hinchas a la
oficina hoy ya tenemos una idea cuando
oiga que por el precio una boleta vamos
a ir a todos los partidos como antes a
la trampa no hay trampa
la realidad es que la tiene que contar
todos preciso nos dio resultado
salimos y vendimos todos los abonos
45.000 abonos en el 2014
tuvimos la fortuna que después de tener
el estadio lleno y empezará a disfrutar
de nuestra llenos el mismo equipo que
venía clasificamos a traer a los
tribunales
y fuimos tan de buenas que llegamos a la
final y fuimos tan de malas que la
perdimos con santa fe pero
pero seguimos seguimos y eso funcionó
entonces que hicimos volvimos a hacer el
dos en uno y en el estadi
volvimos para la final y la volvimos a
perder con el cali pero seguimos con el
optimismo
y todavía compran el abono todavía
compran de la hoja o john page y la
compañía se transformó se volvió una
compañía que se volvió más rentable no
con su boletería que sino con el
mercadeo porque todo el mundo quería
pautar en el medellín porque tenía el
estadio lleno ser ganadas más por otros
paramos más bueno
la apuesta olímpica es muy bueno no
no mentira al grabar en el circuito al
lado
es la historia digamos que no funcionó
pero alrededor de todo esto juan y bueno
ya cuando teníamos
y los equipos un poco estables ya
digamos cuando con la amistad que
teníamos el barullo que nos conocíamos
desde la universidad y que cuando él
estuvo en millonarios como presidente
también habíamos tenido esa cercanía y
ya cuando llegó a nacional pues ya
teníamos digamos una una relación pues
más estrecha y nos dimos a la tarea de
que proyectos podíamos desarrollar y
trabajar juntos porque ya estamos un
poco estables en la parte deportiva y
ahí fue donde dimos el mensaje de que
nosotros éramos los primeros que
teníamos que dar ese mensaje de
convivencia con todas las hinchadas con
nacionales con medellín y miren ahí
cuando nos dábamos ese abrazo y el
saludo antes de iniciar un clásico
no toda la gente lo recibía bien al
principio pues como saludas al
presidente del medellín a eduardo le
decían lo mismo es que nosotros somos
los primeros de que tenemos que
propender por esa convivencia y dar ese
mensaje y ahí nos fuimos yendo fuimos
yendo se me fue una perdón
aquí está empezamos a trabajar otras
sinergias la cine es la principal
sinergia fue que nos volvimos la ciudad
futbolera de colombia queríamos hacer
eso y dar el ejemplo de que nosotros
queríamos que siempre se jugarán las
finales acá en la ciudad de medellín
obviamente yo quería que fueran de
nacional y él quería de medellín pero
entonces no colaborábamos en los temas
administrativos y comerciales para poder
trabajar en ese sentido o no eduardo si
les cuento imagínense que en medellín en
un año entre los dos equipos ingresan
más de dos millones de habitantes a ver
los partidos de medicina nacional
la ciudad más cercana llegan 700 mil
personas más o menos el estadio ya nos
volvimos en la ciudad más futbolera de
colombia nos vemos ejemplo y no sólo eso
empezamos a hacer un trabajo que es
gracioso porque juan iba a los novios a
llevarlos a buscar patrocinadores y nos
decían no no le podemos dar patrocinio
al medellín porque quedamos con hincha
de nacional igual iba a donde el mismo
patrón orioles ya no le compete al
patrono nacional porque hay que amar con
el mediático los hinchas del medellín
tenemos vamos juntos vengo a trabajar
juntos por el mercadeo igual nos dieron
que no pero vamos pero ya nos
comprometíamos
no mentiras y empezó a funcionar
empezamos a ir ya construir las dos
instituciones de la mano hacer cosas
importantes y a buscar quien no es que
no la apoyará y lo fuimos logrando y no
sólo en el mercado también lo hicimos en
la parte social y empezamos a ver la
parte de convivencia porque en esta
ciudad nos dimos cuenta que había muchos
enfrentamientos y nos encontramos con
cosas
totalmente cerrado increíble después de
esto pues de lo difícil que era la
convivencia servida y lo dedicamos a
sentarnos con las barras y hacer que
funcionara que tuviéramos tolerancia y
cuando llega vemos a cada una una imagen
de un gran líder que tenemos como de
ciudad como del pse el alcalde federico
gutiérrez y nos da ese espa ese apoyo y
ese espaldarazo que necesitamos nosotros
los clubes y otra vez que el fútbol y la
fiesta en los clásicos volviera al
estadio y ahí empezamos a trabajar
conjuntamente para que fueran las dos
barras las barras los hinchas de
nacional y los hinchas de medellín a
compartir de nuevo en los clásicos y
darle el empoderamiento a cada uno de
los hinchas del que la
embarraba tenía que pagarla y así fue
como empezamos a trabajar pero esto ya
van aproximadamente 15 clásicos desde la
política de la alcaldía de federico y
cada vez vamos mejorando en ese sentido
y vamos buscando de que podemos seguir
trabajando en esa convivencia y hoy les
contamos somos amigos socios trabajamos
y tenemos una compañía y trabajamos
mucho para la sociedad nos dedicamos a
estar en todos los barrios de medellín
ayudándole a todos los equipos de la
ciudad que son más o menos 600 clubes en
la ciudad de equipos de futbol
basquetbol volibol gimnasia a todos les
ayudamos nos sentamos a llevarle era
como construir un mejor club como
generar mejores ingresos como
administrarlos mejor y vamos divulgando
eso por todo por toda la ciudad una de
la ciudad y de hecho el bar tos del
complemento
habían esas diferencias en las comunas
de que habían clubes que no se hablaban
imagínense después digamos las comunas
clubes aficionados que manejan jugadores
aficionados deportistas aficionados y no
se hablaban y tratamos de integrarlos
desde el punto de vista administrativo
pero también de generación de recursos
lo mismo que hicimos nosotros en los
clubes decimos ese mensaje y hoy en día
pues digamos hemos avanzado con algunos
clubes en ese tipo de fortalecimiento
los unimos a todos por comunas y les
enseñamos a cómo trabajar en equipo a
cómo hacer proyectos papeles mentir al
sector real y poder buscar recursos para
todos los equipos en conjuntos y sin
diferencias fue difícil pero lo logramos
y por último un tema importante que
trabajamos era también la convivencia en
los colegios visitamos colegios e
instituciones educativas universidades
en estos días estuvimos también en
bellavista un tema trágico durísimo ver
eso allá y tener problemas de
convivencia también de va ritmo en
bellavista es muy difícil y eso pasa
mucho entonces vamos y les demostramos
también a toda la gente de que nosotros
podemos estar en familia podemos estar
juntos y que podemos disfrutar el fútbol
en paz que nuestro principal objetivo y
hoy en día nuestras vidas
ejemplo en convivencia y en tolerancia
para los que no grande el fútbol en
diciembre o en octubre cuando se lo
hagas la final de copa libertad entre
boca y river que no se pulgar por la
violencia tanta buena imagen tenemos y
tanto hemos creado como ella esa es la
idea de que medellín ya tiene tolerancia
en el deporte y en la convivencia que
nos buscaron y trataron de hacerla acá
pues estuvo dentro de las posibilidades
para que sea esa final segura acá ya
para expedirnos de verdad un mensaje es
decirles de que nada sirve ser exitosos
o ganar títulos logró ser exitosos en
cualquier campo de la vida si no
trabajamos por la sociedad y por la
comunidad
eso es una reflexión y un mensaje que
queremos darle a cada uno de ustedes y
el mensaje que nosotros propongamos a
dónde vamos de que siempre pensemos en
el componente social de que la gente de
medellín la gente de colombia hay gente
buena mucha gente nos ha mitificado por
mucho tiempo pero nosotros somos gente
berraca gente echa para adelante y si
todos nos juntamos vamos a seguirse
haciendo equipo para salir adelante
bueno y seguir william bregando que
estas unidades
por cada día estás
[Aplausos]